TOGETHER TO DO WHATEVER THEY CAN
TO -- TO HELP IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST RUSSIA.
IN A VOLUNTEER CENTER IN LVIV,
MOMS WHOSE HUSBANDS AND CHILDREN
HAVE TAKEN UP ARMS, GATHERED
SUPPLIES FOR THOSE FIGHTING IN
THE EAST.
>> Translator: WE UNDERSTAND WE
NEED TO HOLD STRONG.
WE HAVE VERY STRONG FAITH.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE WILL WIN, AND
THIS WILL HOLD US TOGETHER.
>> Reporter: SHE WORKS FOR A
GROUP CALLED ANGEL ON YOUR
SHOULDER.
SHE'S RECRUITED WOMEN TO PACK
BOXES AROUND THE CLOCK.
>> NONSTOP, NONSTOP.
>> Reporter: EVERYTHING IS
DONATED, MEDICINE, TOILETRIES,
ALL KINDS OF FOOD.
YOU ARE LOOKING FOR THINGS THAT
ARE EASY TO PREPARE FOR TROOPS
AT THE FRONT OR FAMILIES.
NOTHING STAYS HERE FOR LONG.
THE WORK IS HARD.
THE WAR IS HARDER.
ANGELA'S HUSBAND LEFT FOR THE
FRONT YESTERDAY.
>> MY HUSBAND YESTERDAY.
>> Reporter: HE'S A DOCTOR, A
VETERAN OF THE SOVIET WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN.
>> DOES IT HELP THE WORK HERE TO
STAY BUSY?
>> Translator: WE ARE DOING WHAT
WE CAN.
WE KEEP ON PRAYING.
PEOPLE ASK HOW YOU ARE NOT
CRYING, BUT, YOU KNOW, CRYING
DOESN'T HELP.
EACH PERSON DOES WHAT THEY CAN.
>> Reporter: ANGELA IS IN THE
RESERVES AS WELL, BUT FOR NOW
SHE'S TAKING CARE OF HER FAMILY
AND VOLUNTEERING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR STRENGTH.
YOU GIVE -- YOU GIVE ME AND
EVERYBODY STRENGTH.
>> Translator: THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>> Reporter: IN ANOTHER
BUILDING, MORE MOTHERS, MORE
VOLUNTEERS MAKING CAMOUFLAGE
NETTING TO HIDE TANKS AND
ARTILLERY.
>> IT WAS NOT TRUE.
>> LET ME TEACH YOU.
>> DO YOU SEE?
>> JUST LIKE THIS.
>> ALINA'S SON IS ALREADY IN THE
FIGHT.
WHAT MADE YOU WANT TO COME HERE?
>> Translator: WE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR COUNTRY.
IT IS DIFFICULT TO SPEAK.
MY SON IS IN THE ARMY SINCE
2015.
I DIDN'T WANT TO LET HIM GO, AND
HE SAID, WHO WILL GO IF NOT ME?
HOW WILL I BE ABLE TO SAY TO
PEOPLE THAT I HID AND SHELTERED?
SO, HE LEFT, AND IT WAS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR ME.
>> Reporter: MANY IN THIS ROOM
HAVE HAD TO FLEE THEIR HOMES IN
KHARKIV AND KYIV.
THEY WONDER WHEN THE BOMBS WILL
FALL HERE.
IF YOU COULD TALK TO MOTHERS IN
RUSSIA, WHAT WOULD YOU TELL
THEM?
>> Translator: I WOULD TELL THEM
TO TAKE THEIR SONS BACK.
WE ARE ALSO SORRY FOR THEM.
THEY ARE ALSO HUMAN.
HUMAN LIFE WAS CREATED BY GOD.
HOW CAN IT BE TAKEN AWAY JUST
LIKE THAT?
THEY WILL BE JUDGED AND FACE
PUNISHMENT FOR THIS.
YOU CANNOT DO THIS.
LET THEM TAKE TH